it's my privilege to introduce our
luncheon speaker today frist farmer
Chris president of the buffer growth the
leading limited government free
enterprise political advocacy group he
served on the bubble growth Leadership
Council since 2007 he grew up in
Michigan and met his wife Sarah during
their days in hillsdale college after
working his way through law school he
moved Indiana where he worked for ctv
incorporated a leading manufacturer in
the agriculture equipment industry he
became the company's CEO in 1994 and in
2002 he ran for Congress from Indiana's
second congressional district and
represented that district for two terms
while in Congress he supported
pro-growth tax cuts decreased government
spending personal social security counts
the protection of political free speech
and less government regulation he served
on several committees of course the
Agriculture Committee small business
transportation and infrastructure and
the Ways and Means Committee his
experience in business and in Congress
reaffirmed his long-held belief in the
importance of reducing the government's
reach and enacting pro-growth policies
speaking today on economic issues and
the twenty twelve elections please
welcome Chris Chocola
the afternoon Thank You Anita for that
kind introduction I want to thank
Hillsdale for the opportunity to join
you today as Anita said I am a hillsdale
college graduate and going to Hillsdale
was the second best decision I ever made
in my life the first the first best
decision obviously was I met my wife
Sarah there 27 years ago and sarah and i
still love to go to Hillsdale events we
love to meet great Americans that attend
these events will love to hear great
speakers to speak at these events and
one of the things we also love to do his
meat to students that currently go to
Hillsdale which i might say are much
higher quality than when I was there
yeah but these students are so
impressive and I got to meet one of them
not long ago at a Hillsdale event it's a
constitution day celebration in
Washington DC and we were at a lunch
much like this and I was sitting at a
table much like that and dr. Arnn was at
the table and Michael Mukasey the former
attorney general the United States was
at the table and sitting next to him was
the student at Hillsdale currently I
think a junior and dr. aren't much as he
does once in a while started giving this
student a very hard time and he started
asking or simple questions like what is
the meaning of life and
and much to her credit she looked dr.
Arnn right in the eye and she said you
know dr. aren't ever since I had you in
that constitution class I'm not afraid
of you anymore I think I need to take
that class because I'm still a little
bit afraid of them so it is great to be
here and my assigned topic today is
economic issues in the 2012 election
after that very uplifting optimistic
presentation we had this morning I'm
tempted to say I think we're all going
to die and just sit down but that
probably wouldn't be but I tell you I
did struggle a little bit with coming up
with my remarks because of the topic
because my experience in Washington is a
member of Congress and is now president
of the club for growth has been that
economic issues and elected officials
elected officials have absolutely
nothing to do with each other because
unfortunately there are very few members
of Congress both in the house and the
Senate that have any fundamental
understanding of how you create jobs
well an economic growth and if you
couple this basic lack of fundamental
knowledge with the fact that almost
every single special interest group in
America hires Oliver Twist is their
lobbyists who is a pickpocket who always
wants some more and members of Congress
perceived that they don't get reelected
by saying no to questions like can I
have some more what we have today in
what we heard this morning is that we
simply have a government that's just too
big to succeed so I think really the
economic crisis in the 2012 election may
be a more fitting topic for our
discussion this morning because as we
heard it's an undeniable that the size
of government has gotten too big dad our
deficit are unmanageable and they are
made minuscule by our unfunded
liabilities I was going to give you a
whole list of statistics to put our
unfunded liabilities into context for
you but I think that was done well this
morning we just had lunch and I think
we've had all of that that we
but as it was pointed out this morning
that you know things that don't can't go
on forever don't and so it really boils
down to what do we do about all this we
all agree we have an unsustainable
fiscal crisis so what do we do about it
and whether we like it or not whether we
intend to or not I think the 2012
election is going to establish a path
that we take and that path is either
going to be as was described this
morning the balanced budget amendment
with teeth we're going to default or we
will renew our American spirit and head
off on a path of economic growth and
reform some people say you know this is
pretty easy why don't we just act like
adults you know if we just sat down and
acted like adults and if the parties
would just put their partisanship aside
and if we could just find common ground
everything you'd be fine well I wish it
was that easy it's not in as my friend
Senator Jim DeMint from South Carolina I
know we got a lot of South Carolinians
here who by the way has done more for
the cause of freedom inside the halls of
Congress than anybody in the last
several years with jim DeMint puts it
puts it very succinctly he says you know
I've never seen a bipartisan bill that
actually shrinks the size of government
and I think for that matter there hasn't
been a partisan bill that shrinks the
size of government either
but you know there is hope I thought I
was going to be the pessimist today but
after this morning I guess I'm the
optimism there is some hope and I do
agree with daniel Hannan when he said
last night that people are really ahead
of the politicians and I believe that
unlike the halls of Congress the
American people still have an
understanding of economic reality they
still kind of get what creates jobs
economic growth and prosperity and I was
reminded of this in a very dramatic way
one day a my way home from work when I
served in Congress I had a little
Roadhouse about a block and a half for
my office which was in the Canon
building and one night I was walking
home late it was dark and out of nowhere
this guy masked gunman jumped out and
put a gun right my ribs he said give me
your money well I was a little taken
aback as you might imagine I didn't know
what to do or say so I blurted out you
know do you realize you're trying to rob
remember the United States House of
Representatives and he looked at me he
said we'll give me my money
so there is hope I think it is as my
master friend pointed out there are
certain undeniable truth when it comes
to economic so one of them is you know
he earns their money spends their money
more wisely than anyone else now he
might not have been the greatest example
of that but you know I do think the
world has changed I think the Tea Party
movement is an indication of that I
think is very healthy for America when I
was a member of Congress I did 150 town
hall meetings I got as many as 0 people
to show up at times and I was a member
of ways and means and the Budget
Committee at work with Paul Ryan and
Jeff penciling and budget process reform
and I would go to my town hall meetings
and talk about budget process reform and
that's why nobody would show up but
today we're talking about how much less
we will spend rather than how much more
will be spent we will spend and I don't
think that we can underestimate how
significant that is and so we've got a
long way to go but at least we're having
the the right debate and for the first
time and certainly in my lifetime I
think people are willing to listen
they're willing to listen to the
challenges that we face and they may
even be willing to listen to the
solutions that we're going to have to
pursue but it's going to take leadership
to get us there more on that in a minute
part of what I think they will listen to
is history and I think history has
proven time and time again when America
embraces pro-growth policies things like
free trade pro-growth tax policy
streamline regulations economic growth
wealth and prosperity are created it
happens every single time on the on the
other hand when America experiments with
Keynesian style stimulus spending
economic growth wealth and prosperity
are diminished happens every single time
the only problem is it seems to be a
lesson that we refuse to learn of course
the most recent example of a refusal to
learn this lesson is the 800 billion
dollar so-called stimulus bill in 2009
which has given us no demonstrable
evidence that is created economic growth
their jobs work so well that now the
president is proposing another
a billion dollars almost and stimulus to
or the JOBS Act but you know this is
nothing new hillsdale zone professor
Burt Folsom Rodin is really great brute
new deal or raw deal he described at the
policies FDR during the Depression we're
really an economic disaster but this is
not just a Democrat problem it has
bipartisan support in 1975 Gerald Ford
tried temporary tax rebates he tried
Social Security bonuses and in nineteen
nineteen seventy-seven out to be outdone
Jimmy Carter tried similar temporary tax
cuts as well as stimulus spending on
infrastructure in aid to state and local
governments and we all know by 1980 our
country was experiencing persistent
unemployment and massive inflation is
recently as two thousand eight george w
bush thought he'd try it and see if he
could get a better result he tried
temporary tax rebates to try to
jumpstart the economy at that time did
little to help spur the economy and gave
us the 2009 obama stimulus bill so this
would maybe lead us all to ask the
question why do we do that and when in
the world and when in the history of the
world his Keynesian style economic
spending actually created economic
growth and jobs well the question is
quite literally never and even the most
enthusiastic keynes ians people like
Paul Krugman who have actually heard
answer this question would agree with
that conclusion but they have an
explanation and their explanation is no
it's never actually worked because we've
never spent enough and this gets where
daniel Hannan described last night you'd
actually have to be an economist to
believe this and they their explanation
is you know we've never spent enough
because in the face of rising debt and
deficits we've lost our nerve and if we
would have only kept our nerve and
maintain our spending case everything
would have been just fine and it's kind
of a neat argument because you can't
disprove it you know you could always
spend more and you could always say if
we just did a little bit more we'd be
okay and I'm afraid that we currently
have an administration
wants to test that theory but on the
other hand it has can it hasn't kept
improving the pro-growth policies like
lowering marginal rates making the
regulatory burden on businesses lower
making us more competitive in a global
economy actually works and you don't
need a PhD in economics to be able to
recite the JFK tax cuts in the 60s the
reagan tax cuts in the 80s and the bush
tax cuts in 2003 now as a member of
congress in 2003 i voted for those tax
cuts and i'll never forget sitting on
the floor of the house in late two
thousand three in early 2004 and
listening to the democrats rail about
the jobless recovery well that's the
recovery that drove unemployment down to
almost four percent and i would say
that's recovery we could use right about
now so history is shown as what works
from a pro growth standpoint and we
could you know say why don't we just do
that but growth is not enough as we
learned this morning we have to also
have fundamental entitlement reform i
don't think any economist would say that
we can grow our way out of this problem
and so we really need a dual path one is
implement pro-growth policies that we
know the history is showing is a path
forward and two is to have the political
will and courage to start to tackle
meaningful entitlement reform so why
don't we do that well the answer is
simple and i think you all know the
answer and that's two things one is we
need leadership and we need political
will to get those things done and they
aren't easy to find but i can recite one
act of extraordinary political will and
leadership in the recent past in my
example may surprise you i have a great
and morbid respect for the democrats and
their health care bill also known as a
volunteer now i disagree with everything
they did but it was a core belief that
they held for over 40 years it's
something that they woke up every single
day saying we have to have nationalized
health care it's something they saw an
opportunity to
do they knew that the public opinion was
not on their side they knew that it
would present a substantial risk that
they would lose their majority at least
in the house but they did it anyway and
is now the law of the land and I'm
skeptical no matter who's the next
president is whether it will actually be
fully repeal and so it was truly an
uncommon act of exercising the risk of
leadership by politicians in Washington
that we almost never see and so in order
for our country to be able to avoid the
impending disaster that we heard about
this morning avoid the crisis that is
undeniable our country is going to need
a champion of economic freedom that has
similar determination and commitment to
put this country back on a pro-growth
path and to be able to attack
entitlement reforms in a meaningful in a
meaningful way we also heard well the
current crop of candidates you know
aren't inspiring us I've heard of
several people say that it was pointed
out this morning I think rightfully they
haven't had time to talk to us the
debates are not a conducive environment
to tackling these issues the enemy of
good government is 30 seconds and that's
all they get and so we are going to have
to find somebody that it can rise above
sound by politics somebody that can rise
above class warfare politics and can
lead the country in a direction the
history has proven works and I think
that we need someone that can inspire a
generation I grew up with Ronald Reagan
he was the first person I ever was able
to vote for my kids Ronald Reagan is a
guy in a history book and all of you
faculty members probably know better
than I that these kids aren't showing up
in your classrooms having been taught
the virtues of the free market system
and so we need someone that's willing to
go and talk about these things in an
unabashed way that people actually hear
them in order for the people to stay
ahead of politics like we talked about
before I think the people will always
stay ahead of politics but I'm not sure
that's always a good thing I think it's
still a good thing today but I'm not
sure it will continue to be if we don't
have education for the next generation
on why free markets work and we really
need someone that can echo the
sentiments of Arthur
some of you may know him the president
of the American Enterprise Institute he
wrote a great book called the battle and
he says free enterprise has done more
for the human soul than any amount of
redistribution ever Ken and I think
that's something we need to instill in
every generation so we need someone that
understands our challenges and more
determined to fix them than to get
reelected we need to find somebody they
can overcome the fear of losing their
job as a politician because now really
is the time for choosing and I know it's
a cliche because every candidate who
runs for every office as in every
election this is the most important
election of our lifetime well 2012
actually might be the most important
collection of our lifetime because it's
a rare election where voters have a
clear understanding of the consequences
of their vote when they go into a voting
booth and they have a clear
understanding that there's one of two
paths we will take after all the ballots
are counted i mentioned i think the tea
party is a great thing for our country
but i actually think the Occupy Wall
Street movement whatever you call it is
pretty good for our country as well
because not everybody's like us we're
not normal we think about this stuff all
the time we come to these events and we
want to do something about it but the
people that don't think about these
things every day do sit in their family
rooms and they do watch TV and they see
tea party and they see Occupy Wall
Street and they will understand that
there's a difference and they will have
to determine which one they identify
with which one of those groups looks
sounds and I guess maybe even smells
more like me
so I think that they are helping to
clarify the choice that we have in 2012
1980 was clearly one of those elections
in 2012 must be one of those elections
because whether we want to or not again
whether we intend to or not we are going
to set a path that our country will take
for the next generation at least and
whether we choose european-style social
democracy like daniel Hannan warned us
last night and all the great things that
go with it chronic unemployment lower
economic growth diminished standard of
living or we can choose to be America
again in other words we will either
choose more government or we will choose
more freedom if we choose more
government I think we know it will
happen we will regain our nerve in the
face of mounting debts and deficits we
will try to spend our way to prosperity
which I don't think is going to work and
we will try to disprove or prove a
disapproval theory and we will spend
ourselves beyond hope if we choose more
freedom I think there is hope but I
don't think they're a certainty I think
organization the club for growth one of
the things that we do is we publish
white papers that's intended to be a
objective analysis of the economic
record of every one of the Republican
presidential candidates I encourage you
to go to our website and look at it it's
Clifford wrote org and if you do I think
you'll probably conclude the same thing
that we concluded none of them are
perfect but I think there's something
else that is true all of them are better
than Obama in all of them have the
potential to move the country in a
pro-growth direction in an order for us
to meet our challenges and if a
Republican is elected in the 2012
election as president they will have to
exceed our expectations in one way that
they can do that is that they can look
to the next store the new generation of
Republican governors people like nikki
Haley who were going to hear from
tonight people like mitch Daniels from
Indiana that I come where I come from
people like Chris Christie people like
rick Scott in Florida people like scott
walker in wisconsin
all of these governors are showing or
choosing more freedom / more government
and they're showing uncommon leadership
and political courage in doing so they
are clearly driven by a sense of
responsibility rather than being driven
by the latest poll and they like our
president they are busy cleaning up the
mess they inherited but unlike our
president they aren't looking for
anybody to blame and so our states are
often called the laboratories of
democracy I think some states today
deserve a different title and that's
roadmaps to fiscal responsibility and
economic growth so history has shown us
a path forward how we can create
economic growth again this new
generation of governors have shown as
bold leadership that's necessary to
start attacking and tackling our
entitlement problems and let's hope the
next president uses both as a guide to
meet the challenges that we all face and
returns America to where we belong and
that's a beacon of economic freedom for
the world so thank you for the chance to
so I guess it will do a few questions if
anybody has any
the club for growth we are we're a DC
based organization we focus only on
federal races House and Senate and we
will get involved in presidential races
state organizations like the South
Carolina club for growth which is a very
good organization focuses only on state
issues in in elections so we try to stay
out of each other's way but our mission
statements are the same when it comes to
policy we only focus on economic issues
pro-growth issues we don't get into
social issues or national security or
any other issues but economic issues we
are not a grassroots organization the
club for growth we have 65,000 members
I'm not sure how many the South Carolina
club has but what we try to do is act
like a vet a Good Housekeeping Seal of
Approval we have a vetting process where
we try to determine champions of
economic freedom that are running for
the house of the Senate we recommend
them to our members and ask them to
support them financially what it does it
gives our members leverage and that they
know that this person is who they say
they are our job has gotten harder
because every candidate running for
every office walks into our our
conference room and says they're their
fiscal conservative our job is to is to
vet that but when we endorse a candidate
will raise between 150 and a million one
hundred fifty thousand a million dollars
for the candidate and we help make sure
that they are viable and we make sure
that our members choose to participate
in the political process by giving
contributions gain leverage our first
focus i'll stop on our first focus is
open safe Republican seats if there's
going to be a Republican that's going to
serve there we want to make sure it's
the most free market pro-growth
candidate possible but our second focus
is incoming
aving badly and so we challenged
Republican candidates in safe seeds that
aren't voting a pro-growth record and
when we beat them two things happen one
you get a better vote until you scare
the heck out of the rest of them and and
that's a motivating factor as we heard
this morning fear is a great motivator
of politicians and we try to make sure
that they understand there's
consequences to their behavior
said Larry Arn to talk to him no one
understands the the argument better but
you know it is all these things boil
down to politicians or opinion followers
they're not Apollo they're not opinion
leaders they reflect what they hear at
home and they'll get away with what they
can get away with and part of the reason
i think the tea party is such a positive
development it is different than the
Wall Street Occupy Wall Street group so
far is that they're trying to understand
how they can participate in good
government and like I said I attend all
meetings nobody came but you hold a town
hall meeting today you're going to get a
lot of people if you're a member of
Congress and so people have woken up
they've decided that their government
isn't what they expect it to be and
they're trying to communicate through
the political process with elected
officials and the tea party I think you
know surprised themselves in the things
they were able to accomplish in the 2010
election I think that they will continue
on that people who dismiss that they
peaked I think are all wrong I think
that the tea party is just starting to
learn the its potential in impacting
elections so you just have to go talk to
them and you have to make it clear that
this isn't what you want is a citizen
Alton well the ultimate answer is the
ballot box the ultimate answer is you
get to vote every four years for
governor and and they understand that
very well well this is going to be a
cop-out answer the club for growth is
not a policy organization we steal from
the Cato Institute from heritage and
from AEI and others what we do is that
we try to comment on proposals and as an
example Rick Perry came out with a
proposal this week we were highly
complimentary of his proposal and if any
of you haven't looked at it I'd
encourage you to do that we have not
made an endorsement in the presidential
election but we think that his proposal
is bold it gets to the reforms it has a
spending cap of eighteen percent which
is an extraordinary thing if you could
do it has a balanced budget amendment it
has an optional flat tax at twenty
percent it sunsets a lot of provisions
it has a lot of audits of current
regulations and agencies so what we try
to do is make sure people understand
what's being proposed and what are the
pros and the cons of those those
proposals now that being said we you
know we don't take a position on fair or
flat tax we think either one would be
better we think lower lower taxes are
better than higher taxes but this is and
this isn't the question but this is the
this is the real question I think that
we all are going to face we heard this
morning that the super committee will
likely fail and that's probably true or
else they'll do something that will be
very disappointing and none of us will
believe that they'll actually achieve
the cuts that they say they'll get a
more interesting question is if they
could get to a point where they propose
fundamental tax reform by broadening the
base and lowering the rates and the math
just happens to work out that revenue
goes up would a pat toomey or a jeb
Hensarling
or the club for growth or grover
norquist or any groups think that's okay
and that's that's a very complicated
question because if you lower the if you
broaden the base and lowered the race
you could make an argument depending on
what they're offering that that's very
pro growth and if you believe in the
Laffer curve you shouldn't have a
problem if revenue goes up because if
you believe in that kind of growth and
the pike it's bigger that's a natural
outcome and so that's what we would love
to see that's what we'd love to come in
our real proposals like that I don't
know where we come out or anyone else
would come out but if the super
committee was going to do his job I
think there is a scenario where they
could get the votes to support something
like that but everyone's going to have
to be very disciplined I think their
criticism and studying before they come
in
in the last 30 years is only at the
short-term effects of some in Congress
in society whereas of course but also
we've seen the long-term consequences
can be devastating and of course I see
recently more and more projection law
firm all that you see this happening
there's more consideration long-term
effects
on the term limits yes I think two of
the greatest reforms that we could have
in America is one is nonpartisan
redistricting if you could actually
achieve that because there are so many
safe seats in America that people are
motivated by the voters in two would be
term limits that's not an issue that's
on our menu at the club for growth I
took a term limit pledge when I was in
Congress my term ended up being more
limited than I pledged but but I do
think the term limits would be a great
reform and help you know help help help
us to get better government as far as a
short-term versus the long-term view I
don't see it you know every every
question I say is this new or has it
always been like this I think it's
always been like this I think that's
human nature and certainly when members
of the House have to run every two years
they have a very very short term view
but what the one thing I learned when I
was in Congress is the only thing that
really matters is who pushes the button
and what do they get to push the button
for or against you have this little car
your boat card there's no machine you
stick it in and there's yes no or
president and so who's pushing the
button what do they get to push it for
or against in legislative bodies our
team sports and you need more your guys
and they have their guys and you need to
have enough guys that get to send the
agenda and so until you get people that
are committed to doing the hard things
and that's what we do i'm not here to
pitch a love for growth but that's the
only thing we do at the club for growth
is try to improve the gene pool of
congress by finding champions of
economic freedom will take these beliefs
to Washington because you'll never find
them there and so they're willing to
take the risk of leadership they're
willing to put their job on the line by
taking hard votes because there's this
circular argument in Washington I have
to take I have to be irrelevant today so
I can be around to be irrelevant
tomorrow because if I'm relevant I might
lose and so you have to find people that
are willing to get beyond that we have
been successful in finding
some people a lot from South Carolina it
was just saying if the whole country was
like South Carolina the country
well if I understand we're holding the
gun to our own head we the people of
America get to decide this the but the
reality is Rp bring up our AARP is a
special interest group it's a lot of
members I don't think they're members I
don't think they necessarily reflect the
views of their members all the time but
they have 50 million members or whatever
it is and they vote that's the key is
they vote and so we heard this morning
seven year olds about seventy percent 30
year olds about thirty percent and
that's the key until you get to people
that are paying the bill to vote and
have an educated vote this is a this is
a death spiral that we're in and so you
need politicians and that's what we're
trying to find the club for growth and
what we all should find that are willing
to tell the story drilling to level with
the people and I do think that certainly
in my lifetime people are more willing
now than ever to listen now you can fix
Social Security relatively easy there's
a thing called progressive indexing it
takes care of seventy plus percent of
the problem it can be demagogue
politically but it's a responsible way
to do it so security has about four
moving parts Medicare and Medicaid have
about a thousand moving parts until we
can get to the point where we can
address have a serious discussion about
Social Security the future is
challenging but it all boils down to who
votes and in getting people that are
willing to fight the fight thank you all
very much appreciated